[Music]
you mentioned how you were influenced by
like Buster Keaton you mentioned Stan
Laurel yeah Stan Laurel one of the great
comedians of all time of Laurel and
Hardy when you became famous you looked
him up in the phone book he was in the
phone book isn't my accident I was
looking up something else and it is said
Stan Laurel I thought it can't be and I
called up and it was Stan Laurel
absolutely amazing oh yeah so he was
living in Santa Monica in a little
apartment and I would we just started
doing the the Dick Van Dyke Show so he
knew who I was and I said what a fan I
was and I said you know I've stolen from
your pretty liberal over there they said
yes I know that's what I'm about comedy
is it is a chain I I grew up looking at
people like Johnny Carson you and you
said you just take things you don't even
feel like you're taking it it just
becomes part of your DNA no and then I
find out that that that you're getting
stuff from Stan Laurel Johnny is is
getting stuff from Jack but Jack Benny
the stairs and you realize okay it's all
part of of a change oh yeah
it's passed down the the Dick Van Dyke
Show when I was a kid it was the first
show that was in my opinion was her
first show that really talked about show
business and how it worked because the
show was about a comedy writer yeah also
about his family but about this show
that he worked for
so it really introduced the idea that
there are comedy writers to Americans I
think a lot of Americans didn't think
about that of rosie's they didn't they
just thought oh Sid Caesar these guys
they come out they're funny and they
were actual there's a writing room yeah
so many young writers come up do you say
they thought of becoming comedy writers
because of that show we seem to be
having such a good time they found out
it's not quite like that well you know I
started out as a comedy writer on these
different shows and the first thing that
stunned me is how many writers were in
the room because I grew up on your show
there's three writers that's all we need
is three writers and then you get on
star not live and there's 65 right
no it's just have three let's have Morey
Amsterdam what's heavy a-road boroughs
Moran will be fine
did you I know that chemistry was such a
big part of that show in your chemistry
with Mary Tyler Moore was just pitch oh
she was so letter perfect she had never
done comedy and by the third episode she
was as good a comedian as I've ever seen
and she could read your mind she was
great at improv
the Karl could give us a scene to do and
were just improv it and usually use it
that way
that's how good she was now people you
were such a convincing couple people
thought that you were a real couple yeah
that's right I I started at another
series after that with another lady and
I was in this play
yeah a woman came up in the market and
hit me with her purse he said how dare
you read that sweetheart
did she give you any Conan keychains
[Applause]
[Music]
is it true I heard a rumor once I don't
know if it's true that the Johnny Carson
had not started the Tonight Show I don't
think he started his Tonight Show till
1962 that he was considered possibly for
the role of rob Petry that's what they
tell me I don't think he ever auditioned
or anything but they were considering
him thank God it turned out the way it
did because I would have been rotting on
The Tonight
[Applause]
you